given any complex number in polar for
tomorrow suitors states that if we raise
that complex number to the nth power
what do I get ok what happens to
Experian because we're multiplying mods
if you're multiplying Z by itself n
times you'll want to apply the modulus
by itself n times okay that's that pot
what happens to the arguments very good
and theta here as well okay because
we're multiplying modes but we're adding
arguments so far so good right I will
say this is by Democracy Now by writing
it now when you can see we're going down
in this direction right
the mind is there and gives you palace
new powers like raised to the power of
two three four five or even negative
numbers that's fine that's division
right but complex roots roots is about
going in the opposite direction
but if I say square root or kukuri or
four three or whatever right it's
instead of multiplying it by having it
division right so if I go backwards well
okay let's think about what we would
guess to be the case if instead of
having it powers it what if I had the N
three I was here what would you guess
the de maras theorem would kind of like
generalize to in this case it's okay so
that's just yet this is the next one
right so yeah because in index form this
is said that I 1 over N everywhere I
have any key on I could replace it with
whatever it up here by is that okay so
I'm gonna write that out just at the
front because aa to pad one of it is
just the N 3 right what about the
arguments what happens we multiply minds
we should add arguments so the opposite
is division right so I'm gonna get this
okay now this is fine this is true
excuse me there's nothing wrong on the
board it's just that it's not complete
right so you know we talked about all
right what's the square root of 25 right
and the scribe 25 is 5
but 25 has two numbers which are equally
square roots they're not the square root
but they're both numbers you can square
that will give you 25 right so of course
the equation that would give you those
two solutions is x squared equals 25 we
know this is 2 ounces
oops so plus or minus 5 are both square
roots of 25 right but 5 is the square
root if you remember what we're talking
about in the complex plane we talked
about two finding another based on its
module sense argue and we said ok if I
have a number here okay 1 plus I have
something like that I could say it's
argument is pilot for but that's not the
only argument I could use right like
give me the example what's another
argument I could put on there if I add
multiples of like this is fine for and
if I go then angle and then add another
2 pi what's pilot 4 plus 2 pi 2 pi is 8
pi and 4 right 2 pi is 8 PI over 4 so
when you add to that point 4 you'll get
9.40 k so we have this non unique
representation ok so just like I have a
principal argument I also have a
principal square root right there's one
which I consider like the main one and
even though there are others sort of
hanging around on the side right but
when you look at complex numbers things
open up a lot more than this right
another has two square roots what about
if I asked you for okay so this is just
the same number right how many cube
roots are there hundred twenty-five
now interestingly
excuse me in the real number well and
the real number one I would say there's
only one solution right there's only one
solution but we know in the complex
world we find more okay so to help
unpack this I'm gonna show you an actual
example let's find easy to be them let's
find the cube root because that's that's
the one where that's the first time
we're in country you know this issue or
how many [ __ ] this is the key of a
nice simple cop excel but like saying
super public the moment like say 101
okay now just a little side note excuse
me the number one is an important number
right just like it's an important time
cues a unit circle and that kind of
thing so in the context of complex
numbers we give it another name
just like zero has the name origin we
call one as in units Vizzini okay so
what we're fighting right now the cube
roots of unity and I could find the
square roots of unity and the fourth
root of unity I can find whichever one
so what I'm gonna do is rather than your
appeal to this which I know will only
give me one answer by definition if
you've got something you divided by
three right you're only gonna get one
number okay instead I'm going to use the
pop-up to my spirit right this guy here
so what that means is I can solve this
equation the cube root of one if I cube
them
I should get one do you agree with that
so in other words I'm solving this
equation you care with that